it started up yeah whatever you guys
know camera on camera everything's up
take it easy to take on dude relax
oh you're not even a real Mets fan take
it easy um New York kid dude now you're
a kid I got Jay with us I brought shark
guys doll smile I'm sorry guys my first
appearance out of about 600 podcasts has
never been on there and then amazing
your own brother and you wouldn't have
month well he doesn't much it's not what
he does not what he does how about more
walking in cuz he's been with me all
morning right shot below the belt and I
thought then I shot a food truck dives
with Dustin Poirier and fed Jay chicken
and waffles hot wings with waffles and
he's been trying to hang with me coffee
wise drink coffee yeah or walking is
we're about sorry were three myths wait
is he sweating ago what's wrong with you
many of us are we almost there
yeah why us I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants work
start recording is is there about he's
been waiting I forgot that's pretty
gotta hit the [ __ ]
he's his settings so are we starting now
you know why he goes out to go to the
bathroom you know can't came to me so it
and he's not like he gets so embarrassed
I go can you take Jay the bathroom
because it's just [ __ ] he's Nigel's not
a nice guy I just got a piece good thing
I don't have to shoot him take him do
they take him to the pool house cat cat
walk don't tell me we're even talking
about this no he's so find out when he
when he listens to you tomorrow in the
park yeah dude don't apologize dude well
it's waiting i I'm just gonna wait now
what we've known each other a while
yeah reason I'm in stand-up comedy I
mean just no nice in a little while yeah
how long that we I don't know what
you're we in 2019 2012 yeah seven years
I see more than I see anyone else on
this planet yeah I know we've talked to
you more than anybody in the world yeah
who's Bryan Callen that'd be you yeah
but who's the Bryan count on the special
thanks on the end credits
that's a different Brian okay have you
never met him I haven't met the guys he
spells it Bri I and right not be ry and
because I felt like I would I deserve to
slot in it - I stopped there any of you
a picture yeah Alice
yeah like I closed without the story
about instead of comics sure
and somehow they decided they go hey who
do you want for the special thanks I
said WAP see Rogan Callen Feldman Justin
ed Brooke yeah and then what yeah Bert
Kreischer yeah yeah no doubt and then
they spelled your name wrong how humble
dude I was so mad when when you I know
you hate me that
I don't a lie yeah you're so detailed I
just kept getting texts from people you
know I don't give a [ __ ] but it was just
so funny and then I all I said was I
said but beep Brian sent a picture of it
but Brian Brian judge go around there
who's Brian and and I just got Jesus
Christ I was so mad I said the loser
how the [ __ ] who did this how's this
happen out of all them how's this - yes
how do you matter about the end of the
but at the same time it's an easy fix
alright but how can I so she ate with me
and know the things I do and then I sum
the list with the correct spelling
obviously I don't if you spell your name
Bri and suck a dick it should be BR yaa
and I send it to them who would just buy
oh it's Brian and when you know the
history of yeah how craziest well you
know people right you know people do it
if you know how does Game of Thrones
leave it leave out a cup of coffee on
that was crazy storm editor same editors
same air guys just missing [ __ ] way
to go guy name of Thrones waiter job
special he misspelled Brian's name he's
busy wanker sleeve there was plastic
water bottles on the final on sets now
that's a lot of stuff shaking up I would
get to a beloved's fake pepper cow [ __ ]
in um but yeah man we had a fun party
yesterday we had a fun party yesterday
appreciate coming well kiddoes Brendan
had a pasta truck first time I've ever
had a pasta truck that was good homemade
pasta right mm-hmm what was it called
art street to prince of venice present
venice prince of venice good stuff can
you get out my driveway stay at the park
kind of in the street yeah
there's still fun though you were Balkan
well I only had one little small pasta
bowl yeah yeah your wife put my girl on
notice no why because of how clean that
house is and how organized things are uh
my wife cuz I wish I was like this hate
just not I'm gonna say this I'm saying
once Johanna games gains come at us
[ __ ]
Joanna Gaines come at us [ __ ] yeah her
husband chip yeah bring it
duster because that you know wanting it
dude because bring your Bible yeah bring
your stubby little wife yeah come over
the crib
let's compare cribs she she walks around
the house probably I think she just
kinda goes she just uses her finger and
looks at him guys if there's any [ __ ]
dust people die cuz yeah that's right I
love my Mexicans dude love my Mexico
knows a lot of Mexicans in a household
tons of Mexicans rocks in Spanish a lot
of Spanish beyond broken I don't
appreciate it a lot of my just Spanish
surround me and your nanny she watches
over Tiger like a hawk not a lot of
smiling goes on all business and doesn't
understand English so when you ask a
grandma that's not grandma that's just
that's nanny that's nanny doesn't speak
a Linda doesn't speak a word of English
your son is gonna be fun that ruined
he's gonna be a a muscular a giant
muscular J Shaab looking Tony Gonzalez
Tony Gonzalez very very tan right now
he's got he's got you see out of your
face in there Jay yeah he's a
good-looking kid
alright Jay's never been on the podcast
shark eyes dull smile here yeah I got em
bullied out that was okay so it's in New
York because we were sitting ringside
for the wilder fight yeah so we had to
get you know with you get outfits cuz
we're on camera yeah he shows up and
sweats in a tent what are you doing I he
goes what do you mean I go were you me a
TV man
you get Burmese eating rinks I guess
I'll [ __ ] it's good to go shop in New
York City you had to be a better place
to shop in New York City well first I
might like - more than you is chase
shots bastion Yeah right he came in
jeans and a t-shirt
well we can't have that
yeah that's comfortable now now I'm
looking out thick you are I looked at
your dad's back yesterday awesome spot
before the Silver Fox in I took him in I
took him in and he's not a weight lifter
he doesn't lift if he lifted old
heavyweights he'd bet he'd be like you
you just cardio yeah he does cardio and
he's and I and then I look at your mom
and must between the two of them no I'm
talking about your mother who I know um
I'm a big girl
biological momma between the two of them
you guys couldn't help but be big you
could not help but be in your mid twos -
yeah it's just in our DNA it's in your
DNA so Jamie and Jason Miguel who's not
small no no he's a he's a he's right
he's basically a Filipino but some
Filipinos look like Samoans and he's
that size yeah but he's on ground like
he's not high body fat I'm being I love
Jason well he's got stuff off handling
cities whatever I love Jason but we're
all eat we're eating breakfast yeah me
Terry and breakfast he meets us look
this so out so else or whatever head
sweating yeah and but he's sweating oh
you want some migas nah fast man you're
not faster than when I go do you is yeah
I like to just fast not eat food on it
yeah me too man and Jay goes yeah take
me to it
yeah all three of us fast everyone huh
not working is it boys I should see
breakfast everyone here is back all
through sir fact all of you are three is
only boy everyone's thickest [ __ ] yeah I
went really
you went fast here how's that going for
everyone because I'm overweight Jason
last I checked you're overweight look at
him just three bully boys look at that
great [ __ ] bully boys he can actually
dance that [ __ ] a Kandinsky he
can dance really well and that's when I
looked at him I was like he may look
like that he's super loud yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah he's a great guy so he meets with
ricin
you know he's probably been to all these
places a million times just takes us
around he's a great dude yeah and you
might be more into fashion than you
don't you think J mmm he's into athletic
fashion yeah he's more into performance
wear right yeah how do you guys sleep
each other are you just
no I know so he's a Brooklyn b-boy yeah
right and and you guys are you guys are
friends yeah
just friends hey you know who cheating
is cheating you were Hey
yeah Qin and Jade would not leave each
other's side does not each other side I
appreciate at least shouldn't show the
[ __ ] up cat what's up man he's busy I
was with my sister and my cousin brought
her fine ass to the party I didn't know
that was loud oh come on I mean I don't
like your hottest sister at the party
but I'm fair I don't dress like a rapper
for sister loves like the wait can you
elaborate nope yeah but you know what
I'm saying nope sure can jerk it mm-hmm
uh yeah we had a that didn't [ __ ]
come man no show that's right that's
right come to Vegas you come to Vegas
yeah I'll come to Vega really you wanna
come to Vegas yeah all right I'm sure
the fans love to see you yeah could get
weird there whatever we'll figure it out
yeah you come out chin Kane wouldn't
leave J side and then you were chatting
up my car guy Greg called the doc on the
car G hours I was with a not for me yeah
he don't waste this time a couple thing
you took him down to my car and then you
like chat about car awful thing I feel
bad I'm here are I told Greg I've told
my dad I feel bad for Gregor's right
Ryan's waste this time thinking about
calls I was with Jay when I was talking
to him so you'll like this cuz first I
look at the Ferrari now that Ferrari
they're not gonna be making those
Ferraris anymore because they're too
powerful because and usually you need
someone from Ferrari to come to teach
you how to drive that car which I'm sure
you know yeah as racy car a racing car
driver I mean I was sitting there and
it's it's Spartan there's no gadgets
it's only for driving fast right that's
craziness so I'm looking at I'm like
Jesus all right whatever I said it is
going a beaut alone it is the thing
Abuna called the stone yeah now when he
told me how much it actually costs if
you bought a new it's a condo on wheels
it's a condo on wheels and it's a nice
condo on with that's fine
Congrats on everything thanks now I say
to him
now I say to him I go Jays there and I
go now what car should I Drive
it's an integrate yeah and then he goes
I mean I'd have you in a twin turbo
Porsche Panamera
bah bah bah bah bah and I'm like how
much does that ego everything you know
is that then I go well what did my
payment he goes about twenty five
hundred bucks a month and I go yeah then
he goes but you know now there's now
what we'd have though there's also the
twinkle and he starts going through all
the details and I go I don't want these
I came to my senses I came to my cell I
want a nice torque I mean looking at our
guy I think now that's a car I can get
you and I can get you in that car for
and I got car will take you out there
I'll show it to you because if there I
go I finally like I don't want a car I'm
out I got bored of the whole
conversation he's a Chatty Cathy dude
it's great though he knows and he's
confident it's just that I have I have
the ability to buy a really nice car
like that and I won't and so many people
who love cars you'd have done it by now
yeah I feel like you know it was Tesla
did you look sick in the target am i
cool dude I like a Targa at the age 52
years old you can have a target right
yeah yeah I'm tempted cuz you can get a
secondhand one for like 60 right or you
can get a newer 999 no no I'm talking
about a 2015 2016
no no not really absolutely okay how
much my spend yeah well for 90 80 85 90
expensive yeah that's what your Tesla's
yeah but I I pay my payments are really
way lower than 2500
my payments are 1100 no they're 1,100
bucks a month yeah fast fast you'd like
to sweep that thing and thanks man
yeah we'll see dude one day you know
maybe I will
we missed you in New York though dude I
know you love New York this time around
didn't you didn't yet it's going to grow
on anymore
well of course it is we're hung out at
Joe's pizza or at a large pepperoni just
shot this [ __ ] [ __ ] man the food just
hanging out in a real city now Paris and
Rome I
the fact that we haven't done Paris and
Rafa huh how far well you can get from
New York to Paris remember in five hours
well so right Levin from LA though you
know that would be well eight eight or
direct light yeah so it's very early you
fly to New York you hang a little bit
have you spent three days there you go
and then we and then we we hop over and
it's a it's a five-hour flight man
you're over the Atlantic yeah it's quite
know what my dream would be one of them
would be to go to Italy Rome and spec a
Ferrari so you pick out exec you want
because it gets to make it like a
two-year waiting Lea would you like to
year waiting list to do it so you pick
out everything order the car then you
can drive one of their cars in the track
and they hang out in Italy for a few
days then fly back I do it yeah but I
wouldn't do it just to hang out with you
too I gotta be honest you want to go
there for a mission and eat something
well you'd be surprised though because
you you see things you sit in structures
that have been around for 400 years 500
years 600 years they made a marble
there's something about that when you're
sitting there drinking wine that was
made a mile oh well I'll go find another
Dame how's that thing doing well not
freedom is I think under reparation
until it's ready to go I'm not going so
that's all I want to see now I've seen
that's not dumb yeah I know you wanna
get a pair so Paris is great
Paris is [ __ ] Jay he's gonna aren't
you gonna Cambodia or some [ __ ] in few
months Singapore in September oh yeah f1
race out there my boy sage Northcutt
just went there asked him how it went
well it'll go better for me Jay follows
the f1 racing series like a psycho yeah
yes it goes right there he falls f1
racing series like roadies follow like
Aerosmith their son back in the day Jay
knows you yesterday what I like about
you is your your knowledge is complete
and thorough I try yeah yeah like you
know you know when you say something
it's almost always a hundred percent
accurate from what I've seen yeah try
that and I've seen you argue with
Brennan and you argue very effectively
Jay hates the well how about Jay doesn't
like the season the game of throne
than I love it well I wasn't I didn't
like the last ones you first huh we're
gonna talk about Game of Thrones finale
in three two one
suck it I'm halfway through where the
dragon burn the Iron Throne how it melts
it I thought he was gonna grab Daenerys
roller in the melted metal and make a
statue damn that would've been a good
idea I mean yeah Tigers can't do that
dragons can't burn down a throne either
y'all items also aren't Dracula that's
not real so if we're living that world
like he could rub her nose and like
roller in the metal like yeah yeah and
then like then they bring it up and then
it's just a statue of her dead body up
then that's yeah I like that idea
yeah have you got to it where the dragon
kills they're like all of John snows
camp and him no you have seen where Jon
Snow is riding it and then other me
about the other mega dragon goes hear
about that you've seen Jon Snow get
melted down oh yes
yo teen was a third eye Raven it's all a
dream Bryan and they're not all really
dead hey I don't want to hear about this
did you ruin everything
[ __ ] if that's me this is all a dream
I'm gonna freak me out
they're not even dragons bro people's
lizards and it's like in suburban LA I
was did you like it when the finale
didn't like this season I mean I didn't
hate it it's still you know I guess
probably the best thing on TV have
usually put that compared to what though
compared to the prior seasons I it
wasn't nearly as good the writing's nice
yeah did you see I'm you're one of those
are you a break your dad's Sopranos yeah
oh yeah yeah your brother hasn't seen
either one and uh
that's incredible of breaking battle it
I know where it goes from here no that's
a great show that's you have no idea
it'll ruin you careful careful but did
you like the wire to didn't you Jay yeah
where's good I don't love that felt
a policy therefore what do you think a
last night cat I felt like it was a lot
of exposition that never paid off
I was unsatisfied like what's the point
of John being revealed as a Targaryen if
it doesn't go anywhere
exactly but know where it went literally
know where he went nowhere yeah also why
would John ready Brian I would John
after he kills Daenerys tell the rest of
the everyone but yeah everyone I killed
her it was me put me away for life yeah
why would he just be like the dragon
took the body away - Mike do cuz he's so
dipped down he's so radically honest the
thing about deputies not as honest but
also shank Daenerys was like you're
always be my queen huge well I thought
it was dead that what I liked from what
I've seen oh shut up
it was an amazing this description of
how corruption
I mean power completely corrupts and how
you can become evil when you're trying
to purify the world and free the world
which is what everybody from John Ennis
everybody else talked to Michelle like
Adolf Hitler was stomp out her perfect
world I was like you're the Otzi [ __ ]
it's mouse take Tom's thing I think
malsu Thomas said I 5 to crack a couple
eggs to make an omelet so what well
that's truth but wait a minute
the only thing always is but here's the
other thing the third eyed Raven what's
his [ __ ] name Bryan the kid with the
worst role of all-time in the show how
about he was like I'm not I don't make
decisions I'm just here I don't want to
take any decisions and then all do you
want to be king he's like why do you
think I roll down here I've been waiting
for this my whole life it's like oh now
you want to be king it said [ __ ] for the
past seven seasons so now he's the key
voting him is Caleb right what's your
king I don't want that [ __ ] guy like
this roll em everywhere and he's like
that all dude we really appreciate he
goes you're where you're supposed to be
I just roll him everywhere oh I should
do or I would never make I just left on
Saturday can he walk in the end no no
yeah he get them just jumping jacks King
King yeah thing the King can't dance
he sucks he's like ah he's like I'm
[ __ ] his nose drives me nuts also
he's never done any fighting
sat around I mean I'm sorry that he lost
his legs but still he's kidding now
though he's annoying a superfight start
on my nerves to the [ __ ] redhead
Sansa Sansa got my nerves
what was the engineer real cocky you
know what is Sansa now at hand how she
trusted well she liberated at the north
at the end so brand becomes king of the
six kingdoms
she keeps the north there seven yeah
well the North is its independent even
key to the [ __ ] North who the [ __ ]
wants to be out there I know snow my god
how about area stark was just like you
know what I'm just gonna dip out like
green and go she goes west
yeah well the map doesn't go west she
was cool that's what I'm going she's and
then they did like a Batman scene she's
all she she she she shall see yeah and
now just for walking out well she's kind
of a young warrior but she's gonna get
killed
I saved the nation though you know I
know it's your I go not today I don't
you don't remember that with her but
with like doing all the [ __ ] putting
like the telescope on though they were
walking out the door I think that was
like everybody like the road she's going
West oh man that should be the spin-off
yeah that'd be fun there are gonna be
two spin-offs right three dude there I
start filming the Fed now me watts is in
it
okay just not the excited for like a
thousand or two thousand years prior
though the thousand man like it like it
was any different like technology was
any different yeah it's even worse yeah
I mean swords even though what do they
do use stones to throw at each other it
was before the the iron in the Bronze
Age look at that make up all I think
about is the amount of time you spend
there cup that's all I tell you about
that's a wig you put on a ball paint
I'll tell you to put your hair down put
on a ball paint put that wig on they
already have all this [ __ ] on it then
wet it down with gel and then we'll just
do your face forever yeah but the only
thing is if they if you want to be an
actor you one of the biggest roles of
all time yeah you kind of set like
they're trying to put off what's brought
what's the redhead who I don't like
Sansa Sansa now she's [ __ ] Rogen
new x-men no Jean Grey bad idea the
[ __ ] on my face bro your Sansa you
know give just jump on over while I'm
just kidding I'm mourning the loss of
Game of Thrones gonna jump off but your
agents push you into these [ __ ] epic
roles I would take a seat if I were her
for a second and just find a good role
to play and in another video the Marvel
but we love the Mego Martian figures man
I don't know man cuz Marvel's the star
you're not so it doesn't really matter
anyone could be Jean Grey have to be
magneto yeah she just has her voice and
she's just sitting there talking and
then she has to do a press tour it's
[ __ ] boring dan McCutcheon spelled
Jean Grey Wow ha this well it would be
Jay yeah mmm I like the jeans sounds she
is hot that wasn't Jay she's married bro
one of the Jonas Brothers swooped her up
she was suicidal T came along with nah
you ha girl why she yep that's what she
said
damn who's not these days though you
know that great buddy
get out of my [ __ ] woman no she can
act
she's beautiful ya know she's gonna aged
good too I think probably like a cheese
man she'll get or she'll get wide no yo
face she's all those pretty people yeah
yeah she's hot dude chefs are taking my
one that Jonas is you [ __ ] yeah not not
Nick but the other Johnson Joe is it
yeah Jerry Jonas yeah the other guy you
know not Nick - Nick bad as though right
who's gonna stop the brothers like we're
getting the band back together makes
like yeah I guess I got I'm so busy but
let you know what I'll jump in the song
the one that only plays the bass are you
ready to go yeah you are the one that
definitely needs the band back together
right because those two brothers have
their own spin-off bands killing it yeah
and Nick's killing and they're all doing
really well the brothers are all doing
really well Nick's obviously killing it
some of the other brother it has a
pretty big band then the third older one
just plays bass there you see so he ded
yo yeah the one in the middle who's
hanging
for her career she's just back there
playing the bass bro so it's his idea to
get the band together super thirsty to
make it happen
could have been worse he could have been
the youngest Jonas oh yeah there's a
fourth one and he tried to get his own
Disney show because they had one and
Disney passed on him are you gonna pass
well look I I know Nick a little bit
he's he's a great [ __ ] guy so I don't
want to say anything bad about his
brothers because oh damn there's a
fourth Jonas brother you know it's so
weird timeout Hanson what the [ __ ] huh
weekend you had a long weekend yeah
attitude I'm over when you were bulking
last night too I saw you going for
second third nope I only had one thing
to posture up starving really yeah
there's any possible right who's allowed
there's a fourth brother looks like
that's a baby well know him as a growl
there look at him yeah I think it looks
or singing come on [ __ ] dude don't be
mean oh I'm not me that's life the other
ones are looks alright
compared to knit though well Nix Nix the
king well the other brothers not bad
either Nick is Nick like she doesn't
look like he's one of the four oh you
gonna do a lineup like which three are
brothers you like what nothing yeah
he doesn't look like a brother hey-up
he's like on the right out of the shot
oh is that the picture of him let's him
it three years old does he nected no in
the real one yes yeah yeah
he's trying though man what do you think
he does there are musicians you know I
can't I have no idea what he's doing
actually that's not a good shot of him
yelling why would it be yelling us wow I
guess he was too young you just oh he
arrested click on that
what are you arrested for being awesome
Oh marijuana let me smoke a little
reefer yeah that'd be tough though you
the youngest brother your three older
brothers like they're in a band
yeah but I can include you they were all
right it seems very well cuz they were
all like very tight they're all
religious right they're all I don't know
I don't think so that dude that kid Nick
is but super 10 like that dude really
just did kicked ass and Kingdom and yeah
I'm only did I i mangy kill I'd spend
time with a great I was spinning I was
shooting when he was doing Jumanji or he
would come to the set and and and I I
didn't know him as a musician right I
just thought it was a kid in a boy band
but I just worry him on the set we
talking and then I saw him sing that one
song and I was like Jesus this guy's the
real deal she's really talented she it
must be fun though especially going you
know craziest businesses any of your
three brothers yeah you guys can tour
together yes Nick Metang make Bank sell
out arenas they have a good guys on a
private plane so I hope so that'd be
cool man got married his girls beautiful
yeah he's one of those dudes who's again
like when you see successfully be like
that disciplined discipline in every out
in every sense of the word and in shape
kids in shape good for him he could
fight MMA right now he was young he's
gay in the show right yeah yeah yep yep
I think he makes out with uh there's a
scene where he makes out what they did
you didn't give a [ __ ] he's just a great
actor he did a great job he came in and
one that audition so when he came in
they everybody including them they were
all like I'm not gonna hire this dude
and you know he's like I'm finally when
you hear Jonas Brother you're like
whatever and he came in and one that
audition he was better than everybody
else and they were like holy Shay's
making out the dude you get him trapped
up on the show - yeah it was the plot
trapped up it was a good show yeah
people enjoyed it I never saw a good
show
his older brother on the show was a good
actor too I like that guy I'm Tucker
yeah yeah he's really good really nice
are really close he is a [ __ ] great
guy you guys are no Tucker from Texas
Chainsaw Massacre dock where he gets his
teeth knocked down his glasses he's a
great areas Jonathan Tucker he's such a
gone he's such a good he would go to him
on touched chainsaw you don't know who
he is he's such a [ __ ] good actor
wasn't that bad you guys would know him
from I think it was a dancer by the way
dancer yeah I think Jonathan was a
dancer but he's I think he's a star I
think he's as good as any so whoa no no
no I doubt it's murdered no but he's a
good actor man that dude can do it all
dude he got his nuts and Jonas Brothers
right now second I know I like those to
entomb I work with dudes like that I
like dude no doubt just sweet God I'm so
sweet that guy should be a model in the
middle what's he do now I saw him around
it's all off Abbot one time yeah me too
Bella for I don't know what he does is
hard this business who the [ __ ] knows in
this business you just hope everybody's
making a living we're gonna invite him
to a cocaine party no no he was even a
model for a while there
that's not paying the bills though no
well he's still backed in a bunch of
[ __ ] he's in a bunch stuff
pre-production he's doing the damn thing
hi anything we would know Oh 37 problems
I know that one it's [ __ ] tough dude
radon was tough yeah it's tough this
business is what it is Youth great and
uh Texas Chainsaw though never saw it
with Jessica Biel now that's the most I
did a reading with her too me too me and
Hollywood maybe the most beautiful she's
most beautiful woman I've ever seen in
person she's up there Colorado material
now Colorado born and raised all right
Fairview High School her skin when you
see people like that you go oh well okay
yeah that little attractive dandelion
caught the likes of the old Justin
Timberlake that's right and he could get
everybody wanted and they have a baby
yeah cuz she's also cool and intelligent
and all that [ __ ] look at her fool pack
look at she goes yeah there she goes
there you go there you go my boy bass
she go my boy Ben Bruno trains her well
they could connect you guys now here's a
little line they ask compared to JT
though my friend felt he had a
connection to her psychically the
Titanic reading and he goes I really
want you to you literally get give her
my number tell
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
your friends out of his mind dude
her and I now pronounce you chuck and
Larry when I'm sandwich grabbing her
tits you think she thinks he's gay there
it is that's a great scene okay said her
ass is out she's like do you think this
fits and he's like Jesus Christ yeah
she's a delicious yeah don't be mad at
her dude there's nothing to be mad at
right there and tell her I don't do
what's in the water oh yeah
yes the water bro so water she's good
girl you gotta get you answer there do
you know who aged really well at 54
Elizabeth Hurley have you seen her
we're just talking about her Holy Mother
of God when what before you guys got in
what are you kidding me we're talking
about older I said that older dudes tend
to just look better and the older women
you're right chin you know it's tougher
right you right Doug but Elizabeth
Hurley
take a picture dude you seen Cindy
Crawford yeah I saw that no boo and I
would have given her a handshake
yeah respect her uh-huh but she is
gorgeous uh-huh you seen Tyra Banks
lately amazing just here on the Sports
Illustrated how old is she 59 years old
until that's Elizabeth Hurley well
that's not her now is it that's all
right looks like Brian's whatever
well beautiful all the time is really
fun times choking boy JLo's 5000 there's
number 1 channel 1 that's her right now
goddang gets itself 53 Robin Wright I
saw her oh my god that's her man oh no
no that's her son that'd be tough he's a
good walk that guy too
I mean she's there like yo you gotta run
through Damian before you his her her
son is about the hottest girl I've ever
seen the five I was [ __ ] if I if I
spent one day with her dude how tough
would that be how tough would that be if
your mom's that famous and hot yeah I'm
here the son like Sophie Vera's son
you're just like [ __ ] dude well why
would everyone wants to [ __ ] your mom
Bret off you mom's like a set if we were
drunk and
he whatever was there you know my little
eyebrows we were in Italy and we were
like oh I'm [ __ ] horny and then I'd
be like I might just make out with him
her I would offer you to him to get to
his mom yeah if he was like being a [ __ ]
block when me and his mother I'd say
this I'd say this time I go hey listen
me young man
take this scarf wrap it around your
Adam's apple and and and I don't want to
see the Adam's apple dad his mom is
painfully hot yeah she [ __ ] Bill
Clinton I bet that's true she is uh when
she was younger you not getting better
dude but dazzled
yeah but dazzle she is [ __ ] gorgeous
and and and a good actress and a accent
dude she could be the worst actress in
the world wouldn't notice I was so
distracted look at her she's so hot look
at her accent - [ __ ] look at Jay just a
rock-hard and our boy word boy what's
his name our boy legislature no the guy
was married to her the English guy great
idea Hugh Grant I guess y'all hitched
he's had some tough no he looks good
bring him up June he got caught with a
transvestite or dude you love it
Oh don't judge a book by it's cover
somebody late at night
that [ __ ] he/she jumps in your car
hello old 57 there is marriage age
tested to all of us guys I'm right
behind him he's I really see on your
face I've seen your neck lately you had
the old neck you poo your neck looks
like my elbow look at that though like
your neck looks like my elbow no don't
say that don't say that it's on a big
deal look at here look at yours it's
just what happens dude I don't let that
get you Botox it or nothing at that
chicken skin on the old neck EBU chicken
skin I don't give a [ __ ] though get lost
American elephants look at that down
that's a grill man he looks good though
man sort of for an older dude yeah God
once your looks go let's just all brings
brains the money yeah bring my money
baby
gotta have money you want to keep them
little social butterflies around it with
tits look at them their money Wow Wow
yeah whatever this depressing yes it is
depressing age is depressing you mourn
your youth hey whatever man hey chin
yeah when I came in you were [ __ ]
hating on Ed Sheeran again
yeah why dude he's just copying every
single person's famous melodies like
what let me hear it out any I mean
that's the tough part I like this
podcast we can't really show this song
so you can hear it and then we can
critique it you can take it off and
we'll tell them so this one he does with
Justin Bieber and then one before this
we're looking at it Bieber in in in hit
it this is a new song oh wow then he
grow up
it's a terrible video yeah it is that
beat you know what that beat is right I
hate 10/10 did it and then that it and
then did it intent it it intent did it
intend to didn't I do not keep doing
what is it stand by me he does stand by
me type of beat all or melody all the
time play it for me let me hear it keep
going chin well this video they both
need to grow up though this sucks
yes it is not good there's a terrible
video yeah it is with this sit you guys
back 30 40 dollars [ __ ] between the two
of you why is he in a snow cone with Tia
I don't know you can hear it alright
it's how do you pay attention to know I
can't I'm looking at how bad this video
is you signed off on this what are they
wearing but so there's that right and
then we were watching doing before this
well you guys came here like that shirt
what you guys can make the video here we
could easily do on this green screen
okay could we ever yeah you could and
then when he does a song with this girl
I'm there I don't know who this girl was
but famous so that she can see yeah but
listen to his melody same thing right oh
be afraid no
to be afraid to hear it it's a bit of a
stretch Jim but I feel you know she
looks like Drew Barrymore but she's not
yeah she does have a look Ann Marie
so you think he still didn't get in
trouble he got teeth sued twice all
right and didn't he have to pay one of
them's like a hundred million dollars
what do you have to pay I thought her
wine I think he did and then the next
one is for Marvin Gaye's estate oh
that's right Wow is he still screwed
with a baby they're still going through
it I think I don't know what it is man
you don't mean I like you everyone
company like the music label and all I
mean you know I mean uh I think he must
own whatever that's his music though
right he's creating that music who's out
blinds near the famous one blinder
Stevie Wonder no like Italian Oh butch
oh oh there you go so he has a song with
Bocelli and then if you listen to this
song to only a 192 million B but listen
to the song you can hear it does it
sound familiar at all yeah I thought
he's blind he knows his house anyways
it's unchained melody'
like the exact copy of unchain me you
know Oh My Love My Darling I've hungered
for oh that one hear that song let me
hear would bore chelebi response for
this dude oh I think this is his song
and then Bocelli just featured it
Bocelli
that's his gorgeous wife using Game of
Thrones
yeah you can stop it Jennifer get it
done for YouTube yeah you're right
right yeah so once you start pay
attention to all the songs that he does
it's like but don't you think he knows
now chin do you think I don't you think
he's still stealing [ __ ] get caught in
ruts like I don't know yeah but ruts
this week you've been caught seven times
over less I know I don't know not a rut
after that yeah - bummer
it's very challenge write this song
these are all songs all right all his
real big hits are based off other songs
you know sometimes when you're involved
in an expression whatever it is you get
like writers would get caught up in the
same question over and over again and
they keep answering the same question so
some filmmakers would make the same
movie over and over again from different
angles they like Tarantino has a little
bit of that you know who he said this
new Hollywood film with the Leonardo
DiCaprio Charles Manson by the time he
says the clothes thing he's ever gotten
to recreate in Pulp Fiction Wow so I
can't wait yeah I mean that that movie
was a masterpiece Obie I got this book I
forget out so much in on below the belt
I was on a show with Jim Norton right
yeah and they brought in this FBI
forensic guy he's the guy that showed
mine hunters on Netflix
please interview Charles Manson Jeffrey
Dahmer he's he's the main guy do you
know what his name is Richard Walter
what was Johnny Douglas Johnny Douglas
okay John II dug less they bring him in
whenever there's an unsolved serial
killer case or a murder case they bring
him in because he always sees outside
the bomb yes and solves it he was
fascinating I bet fascinating that he
said when he was interviewing Charles
Manson to a control thing so it was him
and another guy Charles has to be higher
than you so when he was just like
spewing and and branding to his
followers he's always on a chair because
you know he's 5 - so yeah it was the
irony
so he said went to interview Charles
Manson as soon as Charles walks in he
grabbed a chin stood on top of it what's
up and he goes I didn't acknowledge it
but I knew what he was trying to do but
you give him that control can you get
more out of him
yeah so he was we had to look up that
Charles and he would only talk to us
that way it's fat what he was talking
about these in a psychology behind
there's a serial killer who's there
doing his new book his books
it is it's so hot power right power and
like the way people are [ __ ] in it
what a job there he is Johnny doe what a
job what a job he was saying that you
know we're like oh it's just a mental
illness he's like that doesn't fly it's
not mental illness he goes some of these
serial killers and some of these murders
that you meet have the highest IQ the
most normal people you meet and there's
certain reasons why they do it it's not
a mental illness they just get off on
the power right it's a Power Move it's a
sexual they got a sexual pleasure off of
being like that like that they're saying
the guy who remember that guy was
setting up setting fires yeah and then
would watch him yeah they said he would
set fires and the power that that he had
control that the fire trucks would come
and all those people and resources he'd
sit there and jack off watch the firemen
put the fire there's a sexual power
that's right that's what Richard I know
where does that I think it was Richard
Walter said they were finding women by
the river bank killed and he said he
goes plan a car you'll find him
masturbating in his car and and that's
exactly what he was doing they would
find the guy who would pull up in
masturbate and think about what he had
done that kind of [ __ ] this of my
friends a criminal lawyer he had to
defend this kid he kept defending this
kid who he would start a fire and then
dress up like a fireman and drive around
the fire yeah he got off on it that's
very strange
this guy was saying - for this there's
just one murder with a seven-year-old
girl and they found semen on her leg and
that she's been you know braved and
murdered seven-year-old and the cops
kinda horrible the cops came in with
this pedophile rape the case solved done
and he's like you're off man that's it
that's not what's going on here so he
sat down and talked to him and it was it
was a power thing it was it wouldn't
matter if it's a seven year old or a 33
year or 30 38 year old but he just
wanted power over this person so this
person showed up at the wrong time
she was Girl Scout cookies murdered her
but the reason why she had semen on her
legs is because he was so excited -
thought they had this power yeah he you
jack elated yeah yeah but they're like
oh that's easy
pedophile and he's like no it's not you
guys you're so on yeah he has no history
of that if the pedophile he would have
coerced her and set her up and kind of
groomed her this isn't a pedophile case
and he would have done it next door he's
murder murder
murder scenes murders have their own
fingerprint I asked this guy to I go how
can you sleep at night man like you
stole me so you met him I was on the
show oh [ __ ] I thought it was a book
okay so he gave me his book after we had
him I'm gonna read it it was what he
said when you said that he was saying
that night he's like sometimes she's he
has three kids yeah he said yeah
sometimes it's heavy to take home and
give eventually get used to it
because he's seen the worst of the worst
the worst of the worst and I [ __ ] up
and asked the worst thing ever said
there is John Douglas you [ __ ] him
asked him Wow dark shipment yeah super
doctor and he was saying how like the
when these murders and circulars not
really see look you even the murders are
up for parole the parole board's like
are you better did you go through prison
everything all good he's like you guys
are doing it wrong of course he's a
model citizen inside prison because
there's a system he follows each thing
and then moves on you put him in the
real world he's not there's no one
holding his hand he's gonna [ __ ] up
again that's and he knows how to
manipulate you guys I don't think you
should never be that's he goes you can't
manipulate me so he he interviews them
to they sent him when they're up for
parole and man he's good it was so
fascinating dude Wow I think he's
written like four books his newest ones
really fascinating the thing those
things [ __ ] me up though yeah I got
through almost a quarter of it on the
plane and it's so dark it's so dark it's
such a bummer and you know what's
interesting I even occurred to me when
they go oh the the parents need closure
yeah any closure he goes there's no such
thing as closure now so in he said what
else the parents want that in this
seven-year-old who was murdered the mom
wanted did the details the exact details
what happened to his daughter which he
knew of yeah and he was they want the
details he's not for closure cuz they're
gonna have to carry this for the rest of
her life there we want to know you want
to know exactly what she when she said
yeah I can I have a sip so have my
seven-year-old said that oh I don't know
anything I don't know well there's
nothing worse heavy
there's nothing worse heavy but don't
because he said the one thing that did
help the mom is he's like she fought say
that right now she fought yeah it was
nasty man makes you sad yeah man
it makes you sad
it also makes you realize how [ __ ] up
people are because you somehow this
guy's not that how he's not mentally
insane because everything was cat
everything she got played yeah here's
the other thing that he knew he couldn't
let him out of prison because he goes
were you surprised my fingers I was
surprised how hard is to choke a person
at death he was I choked her choked
unconscious left her thought she was
dead
went downstairs to get a bag to put her
I came back she was twitching he's like
what the [ __ ]
so grabbed her by the feet all right yep
she's dirty Shipman
yeah we're not talk about that Oh dirty
but he but he was basically saying how
this guy's been in therapy for 30 years
and he's like nothing's gonna help these
be like no no that's gonna help Aki okay
therapy if you kill a kid or you you
rape you're going away forever you
should but they should just kill you cuz
you like tacos there's the show that
he's like you so much higher than
everybody's and they're so aware of what
you're trying to get out of them so you
said them in this therapist this prolly
not ever
he's our to tell you to get out of
course so you guys aren't helping him
like he's uncurable it's in him that's
what he wants to do
I didn't you kill him put him down like
a sick dog they're saying this this and
this isn't a kid one so it's not as bad
but there was this guy right and he had
he had real bad anger issues and he
bought this he always had bad anger
issues and he killed a guy when he's
like 17 in traffic whatever so he did
like 20 years got out what got out was
out for like a month or so and then what
do you think he's good not this guy the
parolees like he's good he's checked all
the boxes
he's reincarnate he's fine he's way
better we fixed him with therapy he's
good to go the Eve's a young move gets
out a month later he goes he finally
stays money is that he loved motorcycles
goes in a motorcycle shop there's six
guys there and he gets on the bike and
he's like trying to start it he wasn't
familiar with it the guys in the shop
start making fun of him I thought that
[ __ ] you doing you're gonna ride that
thing blah blah and the guys like do I'm
here to buy a bike they start wearing
from you camp I get the [ __ ] out the
bike you're not buying this bike and he
had cash in his pocket to buy bike he's
always wanted guys keep making fun of me
alright cool man
[ __ ] it [ __ ] your bike alright that's
cool leaves
wait a year here goes back in there's no
same six people murders all six the cops
coming go what the [ __ ] man this is a
robbery
they bring in homeboy here goes I ain't
no robbery now this is a path this is
this is all calculate this is someone
who was very upset and something happen
they found the guy he goes yeah man when
her to buy a bike and they in he was
liking they started making fun of me so
he waited a year
just let it stew until they can figure
out was him came back huh that's the
scariest kind of guy and just kind of
guys I'll get you but that's what he's
saying so if you would have interviewed
the guy then with the parole board he
would pass all the tests and be fine and
they'll let him go but there's these
people have these traits inside him
where he might not kill right when he
gets out of prison right but it could be
five years ten years that's right that's
right
the murder room is another book about
this this guy who was like that who
could just solve the craziest [ __ ] the
Craig look at a murder scene and be like
this is a muscular guy who didn't have
sex with her after she was dead you know
what it is it's always the mom
relationships there's always the right
shifts with the mom Oh dad's really
always moms Wow
yeah he's like he's always the mother
son really ship that usually cousin
[ __ ] up if they're overbearing yeah
they say they say wife beaters men who
hit women like a [ __ ] Willy apparently
a lot of times they're men whose mothers
left or had very troubled relationships
and what people listen the first time
okay well there is that there is that
high no no but but but so so that they
can't control a woman so as soon as they
start dating a girl they'll ask for it
they'll don't like it'll start with
little things like where are you what's
your number then then dress me and give
me your phone I want your phone although
I'm and they just start controlling you
that way he was saying I asked him the
toughest case he's ever had to solve and
he said there's the the strangle
strangle torture bang kill bine now find
torchic he'll be flying at the BTK so
the bt a killer he saw that so check the
sign torture so the bind torch goes
28-year career murdering people serial
killer yeah but 12 family took six years
off yeah
so did their fallen tendencies six years
goes by like what the [ __ ] dude where
did they he must have died who got
picked up for prison but then the murder
start happening again he was a family
man
yeah worked at a church yep worked at
her family and you know why stopped his
wife because he used to like do sadistic
stuff so he liked to get choked and
jackoff yeah but his family had no idea
his wife walked in him in a suit choked
himself jacking off and she went what
the religious she went what the [ __ ] are
you doing and he thought because
everyone's looking for this killer and
he you know he had she was like Manny
sounds like the describing is like I
know it's ridiculous right but he
thought man if I get caught again she's
gonna put two and two together so he
stopped doing it for six years or some
[ __ ] like that and then was like oh I'm
good to go
start doing it again after six years Wow
crazy right cuz they were like he was
the only one where it didn't make sense
it never look at look at in there with
his daughter look at him just to just a
guy what is it with it he did awful
things the family would kill the whole
family choked mine yeah torture kill
yeah nice guy that was his slogan look
at this [ __ ] creep what a piece of
[ __ ] of this is creepy oh look he fishes
to chin oh wow that's great click on
that what is that drawing up chin click
on it this one yes the most disturbing
images of what created oh so here just
like that man and women a woman's mask
nice guy keep scrolling down it's so
weird
whoa he would bury people alive I think
that's just his artwork or like oh yeah
yeah it looks like art yeah just messed
up art mmm yeah what a terrible person
man let me kill kids the whole families
and torture yeah it's good guy I mean
you know I don't know I don't know man I
don't know what goes on in this world oh
you know what else it and we'll move on
after murder and death episode
yep shout out to murder in death um yeah
I was asking about JonBenet de palma
JonBenet case yeah
goes i goes the parents right he goes
that drives me nuts he goes he goes know
he was the boulder police runner [ __ ]
it up so bad with outsiders look you're
gonna see me X which ever seen murder
that ain't the parents it's not he was
slamming close
he was that girl was tortured she was it
was not quick the way she was tortured
is not a family member
you'd have to know what you're doing you
have to have time and then I go what
about the brother goes you think an
eight-year-old did that I felt so stupid
oh my god no I mean like was he a I just
went was he eight
now that wasn't the brightest not a
chance he was the way the method that
they used to kill and he was that was a
passion crime they wanted something out
of it he was in it was I can guarantee
it was not the parents he was guarantee
has I've been doing it for over forty
years
Wow he's the one who went and told them
this it's not you guys are looking the
wrong thing so they never caught they
never caught and he was it's not the
parents I can guarantee that and that's
when the boulder police said get the
[ __ ] out of here he said you brought me
in for a reason
I know you guys have been going down
this this path that my parents and he
goes it's so clear that it's not them
saying funny and he was like any goes I
felt bad for the pants you just think if
your child is murdered and they blame
you yeah she died of cancer I think and
then he's like in the Arizona selling
like polo shirt or some [ __ ] Wow well
what about that FBI special though where
they showed that it couldn't have been
anyone that broke in and it was for sure
somebody in the house remember it was on
like last year yeah that was an FBI
recreation yeah they proved that nobody
could come in through the little window
I know they tried to crack where it was
broken because I'm gonna fit through
there yeah hmm it was this thing ate
your life yeah no no I think it was the
Sun just like the FBI said yeah you
think more than the expert who we just
spoke with no there was a eight years
old yes eight well they're not saying he
staged the crime scene the FBI guy said
never got mad hit her with a flashlight
some parents freaked out the basement
wrote that fake-ass letter yeah that
could be possible to save your son yeah
that would make sense
damage dad at 49
well that that was a tragedy all the way
around horrible huh sorry everybody we
hope you're having a great Monday like a
chin kern event if you need help
jay who makes that buttonless sort of
Karthik my car I called the Steven
Seagal no so this is pretty cool it's a
company in a new york city right so this
is Japanese cloth yeah that they bought
from Japan it shipped it to New York and
they you know tailor and put it together
there what that sets you back ball just
like for 25 or 25 G's yeah but you
you've gotten bigger are your arms are
bigger you've been lifting weights
yeah on arms a little more you have yeah
focus arms bigger yeah he's a thick e J
get your dick out for me J right now I
put I put $500 pounds down are you dead
lifting 500 pounds right now yeah yeah I
could do yeah bet I don't deadlift it no
I can avenge - you can deadlift 500
pounds right now yeah yeah yeah that's a
fuckload of weight you could probably do
that I short no it is
I sure could Billy well I'm so much
weaker than your it's stupid like that's
so heavy I don't do a ton of deadlifts
though but if I did I gave you 500 I'm
trying to convince Jay to state of
Wednesday because then I wish you my
down a hike tomorrow watch me out why do
you know we're out the Tommy store
tomorrow yeah just come hang out
I got nothing tomorrow I gotta go back
to work event I told my wife I told my
buys take it just hang out we'll see
there's no reason to go anywhere yeah
yeah you didn't say by the tiger he
calls him uncle Jay running around by
this horse honest self no he didn't he
didn't he think you need to come back oh
he's so cute man stupid he's such a
sweet little frustrating cute oh my god
son with Vinny goes Papa he's my friends
my friend he's my friend he's playing
and you're in Finn you know he's older
he's like he hears you have to keep
telling I'm like finish three dude
I know second why do you keep town on
like he's three man he's excited
right now me and chin tried to get Finn
to play basketball he wasn't having that
yeah my son my son will play a little
bit my sorrows athletic though yeah she
doesn't like my son you mind if I jump
this vent to climb I like probably
shouldn't but I'm sure that's what she
does she was running hills she was
running your driveway don't ask me they
were that's when she gets bored she'll
just do she'll put it my son you can
leave that kid alone for four hours you
know he's doing it he's talking to trees
he's walking he's running backwards me
down right like he's in his own world
bat boy I asked behind why he's hiding
behind the tree like that's what he does
that's what he does it doesn't need you
and I come out okay he goes leave me
alone please
it's like no kill he is writing stuff in
his head I've never seen anything like
it
he was known as imagine if he lives in
his imagination hey hey I do this so I
know but he does sit on a highway higher
level he is going to be a writer without
a question like I watched him he said to
me he goes um I said but you're not
playing with anybody like right now you
don't mind friends come over after
school he goes he said I said this to my
mother he goes I just don't feel like I
need friends sometimes cuz I just have
all these things had to be he's got What
did he say when he walked in my house oh
this is the best he walks in I couldn't
believe he said it out loud he walks in
and he goes yep these people have way
more money than we do you a lion fin you
don't say out loud because I'm just
saying that's so funny to say mom it was
great yep these people have way more
money than we do smart kid like what the
[ __ ] is going on it's hilarious though I
know your house is is nice yeah I think
your house isn't I don't think you'd
ever have to move out of there because
it's it's like birth date in terms of
not too big not too you know it's like
it's what you need that layout is
perfect a rough video yeah but it's
nicer it's got taste it's not gonna Jung
ji Z's house you know nobody's gonna
taste this taste it's tastefully done
man all right let's go to current events
get off my [ __ ] houses no
yes all righty okay so a Pennsylvania
school district decided that they wanted
to make a video teaching other teachers
what to do in case there's a school
shooting and it was filmed and recorded
by some students and they were so proud
of their work that they ended up
uploading the video onto YouTube and a
lot of people found it and noticed that
the person who was playing the shooter
was wearing a headdress
yeah that's an Arabic yeah is it because
by the way experienced it before to play
this shootings are in school are not
done by Muslims they're done by white
kids you know they're done by you know
so that's hilarious that they had to
turn them into it they make sense yeah
it's so sloppy yeah you're Muslim dudes
aren't shooting up nat ghouls now if you
want to play like it's probably you
don't know he mid-size white person yeah
well white kid trouble teens
yeah but I do think that school should
more terrorism yeah you know that that
last one in Colorado is a transsexual
kid did you know that all right
that last shooting in Colorado a couple
we kill got pink dyed hair is a
transsexual kid a [ __ ] or it's like
one of those kids like no no I she's a
have it like taking hormones and stuff
yeah I think so yeah I was right by J's
house yeah right by James I wife it's
right down the street buddy let me go to
that sim school that's new she went to
that school no she's not
yeah that's a why though cuz it's got
built but we're we're yeah well she's
from highlands ranch and we're her PLA
that's right that's like saying I'm from
LA wow so how's race it's not that big
pretty big Mosby's LA but if there's a
school shooting gym bike oh that's where
I'm from
yeah but that's what she went to school
I thought it's right where she did go to
Highlands Ranch but where she lived is
less than half a mile from where that
shooting was like ghouls new though yes
it's a brand new school huh yeah it's a
stem so yeah it's fun to say I went to
school there cuz then you're bound to it
yeah that's a sim school though oh yeah
you sure that that but I thought that
was the skin sim school is that an
addition like she'd like that
no wrong
school nope Brandon school telling been
there cuz room I used to live there J
yeah but in there when you know what
just got it was just being built out
there yeah it's fine she went to high
school uh wait let me see this student
it's fun to say though it's what our
[ __ ] mess you're like super Democrat
do they said like well this is that this
is a crazy person I don't care what they
are the [ __ ] this is a 60 but that's
what this murder was saying we keep
saying these people are crazy it was a
Democrat transgender and a Christian
drug user I mean okay but this is also a
crazy person it did because they're
democrat democrats aren't don't have a
proclivity and transgender pull up
what's this reporter women and kill
themselves a transgender male who's the
myths of transition from a female to
male was born a female fisher named Maya
but prefers these named Alex
alright that's sixteen though right it's
like hmm think this she was eighteen
this one oh yeah what a piece of [ __ ]
yeah crazy person why did she do this
outcast right no friends I never looked
into the story nor Shizuka yeah school
shootings what else you got
boom so this mother found out that her
daughter was being bullied she went to
school and started to threaten everybody
saying that if they continued to
cyberbully her daughter that she would
fight their mom sister or auntie that's
cool
no just the daughter get worse bullying
out when the mom leaves like your mom I
have to come you know I'm saying yeah
this is no spawn go off she's down does
a kid like you know how protective you
get like eyes actually saw this long
nothing wrong no me y'all two bullies
I'm the big book okay this is video from
a free room at Niguel Hills middle
school where Tuesday my middle school
daughter miss school bullying among
girls is terrible it's how far to go
because suicides so high now females in
middle school and anxiety it's something
like they do that or would you just stay
quiet like I don't play this is mom men
and women are just as aggressive as as
each other but women are socially
aggressive Jonathan height does a whole
thing on this women are socially
aggressive little girls are nasty and
this [ __ ] is terrible it's really hot
my daughter's about to go into middle
she gave a faintness that free
ass-kicking must be 18 years or older
Dean
my mom's pretty chewy I like super extra
I love them I like that I'm surprised
school let her in the top yeah same
she loves if I give a word to the class
real quick thank you y'all [ __ ]
I'm surprised the teacher didn't say
anything
yeah yeah well did this teacher's job to
though we're the [ __ ] us why you learn
this bullying go on in your class in my
in my kids school we have they have a
whole they have a whole intervention
program with that I used to always be
like I let the kids figure it out oh
yeah shit's bad way
suicides never been higher amongst
emails this young teenagers that verse
lady solving that right just all about
cyber bullying well uh she get so much
[ __ ] yeah the government said we need to
stop this right now the government ain't
gonna do much but know you have to have
what else you got chin
so there is a clip of Arnold
Schwarzenegger while he's at an Arnold
event in South Africa a crazed fan came
and tried to dropkick him basically
Arnold is okay and he says that he's
just happy the guy didn't disrupt his
snapchat
here's the thing you're free drop kick
on Arnold granted his nickname to the
oak the
keeping budget it's like gonna fly
hitting his back yeah put it in the
video that Arnold post it looks like I
thought yeah her dad
me and Jay over in New York going I'll
[ __ ] some [ __ ] up Arnold but then when
I saw this anger like it wasn't [ __ ] and
the guy does this egg the guy's known
for these stunts
Oh is he oh yeah bag that body goes
really my party guys not weak we get our
own item faced Arnold swole they'll
still swole that okay
what a piece of [ __ ] I exercise boys and
girls so this billionaire his name is
Robert F Smith he is a philanthropist
and he does a lot of investments he was
the commencement speaker at Morehouse
and he said that he is going to pay off
everybody student loans from the class
of 2019 how do you get his money he is
really big on investment so he invests
in a lot of I think big science
companies so he was like yo everyone
here who graduated today paying off all
your student the whole 2019 class that's
everybody all the seniors yeah yeah
everybody who is graduating for
Morehouse he's such a gift for 2018
he did it as a challenge to everybody
who is graduating saying to basically
pay it pay it forward Wow cool dude
that's so cool those kids just got a
huge advantage now no debt and society
yeah that's [ __ ] cool more housing
things the oldest black college in the
nation I believe is it more house was
that how it might be Howard well it
might be more else yeah it's all male
school too right now our house yeah oh
me more houses right no I don't think so
yeah I think you think it is look
didn't-didn't that p-diddy other no he
went to Howard I think oh yeah if you do
groups all-male private yeah yeah my
question Jamin you know if he says it's
worth now man
J knows his [ __ ]
it's all just all guys in yeah so the
girls would you go to that [ __ ] fist
will they ever study probably better
okay sure
but why would you go there well I think
there's like sister colleges so yeah
yeah yeah
come on man I love it live yeah yeah
Georgia Tech up the street yeah just
great school yeah you're engineer yeah
the Bulldogs yeah Robert Pattinson is a
frontrunner to play Batman Matt Reeves
Batman he kind of he has the hit if you
just do this on him he has the exact
nose and face from the comic book he'll
most identical why would you choose that
guy he's not I only choose Michael
Keaton or Val Kilmer Val killer was made
sense Michael Keaton it's got a lot of
personality I'll see this guy having
much personality
Keaton a sense he heard he got so much
better acting though oh yeah like before
he was just about his looks for Twilight
and then he just learned how to do he's
also gone wrong he's also like like very
slight yeah I want my Batman like I like
Christian Bale was thick and strong suit
was thickens no Christian Bale is 220
did that he was big kid there's three
other people that they're looking at we
go school my kids I see him he's depends
on what he's at what he's doing but he
can put on most Honeyman he's not timing
I see him every week be nice to
everything he's in thick heat will bring
up bring him up for a sec where he's out
among Christian Bale well he's lifting
weights and gaining weight he was he's
just dying I see him every week in
person yeah it's not maybe he's getting
ready for a role but he can't you know
everybody small but yeah I mean that's
for a different role though that wasn't
explaining Dick Cheney he got really
phasing driving that look at that
[ __ ] phenomenal actor
you know that's how he looks like right
there that looks yes that's him walking
around no one on this plant would say
he's a thick athletic looking dude
but as Batman he was pretty you go suit
it was the suit yeah nothing he ones
going damn he's a thick [ __ ] athletic
American Psycho he seemed to be pretty
Moscow
they look good in that bring him up in a
min he's [ __ ] doing that huh oh yeah
but you do see Mary there's an iced teas
that's hot man muscular but that was not
he's not to want it yeah that's him yeah
he's definitely not least one in he's
just yeah
he's such a good actor amazing top I've
got five right look I see no thanks look
Adam stop he's a great actor man he's so
good-looking a psycho loves a great
movie yep what else we get this right
here Taiwan is the first place in Asia
to legalize same-sex merge that's right
well say Thailand so many ladyboys yeah
that's a new call go with these guys
all right good for Taiwan yeah ariani is
getting sued ariana is getting sued for
pictures that a paparazzi took of her
but she posted those pictures of herself
on her Instagram it's like hey onnum
that's how it is it's so stupid that's
25 shots number she makes a lot of money
off her Instagram he copyrighted it
himself what a piece of [ __ ] well that's
how you make money oh yeah
but also but it's you yeah it's such a
weird thing are pitting is why I own
this well the only reason you would get
paid for this is cuz I'm in it so how
the [ __ ] do you own it yeah that's so
ridiculous if I don't show up then you
don't there you don't make money that's
so crazy man yeah people suck dude
mm-hmm well he's allowed to post it he's
he sells it yeah
you said that makes it over image too
then she goes hadn't this has been going
on this happens it's a bummer so what
happens is he gets sued and instead of
fighting it and you soon you get my yeah
so this this this says the other
celebrities have trouble posting
pictures Chloe
gigi hadid Jennifer Lopez and Jessica
Simpson you'd be a real piece of [ __ ] at
agra bag I'm soon we got said you know a
suit yeah same reason same way oh yeah
got my break
that guy was a piece of [ __ ] too though
yeah yeah
what else you got Jim let's go if ok you
guys already talked about it but this is
a game of Thrones staying with her
there's a water bottle in the scene do
you guys repeat recalls it seen a lot of
people saying this is fake now so like
remember the nights the kingslayer's
hand that was faked that wasn't real oh
wow I was a picture from behind the
scenes that one of the production people
are an actor took and and you know and
then someone got it and was like look
this in the scene most they put his hand
that of course they put up a table every
word so that's fake yeah I'm sure
there's some bullsh it's just people
trying to [ __ ] on it it's the fun thing
to do now right I mean this is you
[ __ ] kidding me
well that relax it looks like it might
really but it's like a pause scenes here
might be real that's what they're doing
in this he's in finale they I mean does
that had a strange man you know I've
defended this series for this especially
this season for a long time but kind of
[ __ ] out the Starbucks rush the water
cup it's like what are you doing man is
that is that real though I didn't see
this but do you guys remember the scene
in particular yeah yeah this one they
just no you didn't see this thing this
when they decide the third I Ravens King
oh so you did see it yeah well but that
was possible that looks pretty legit
we're sending in the best show yeah area
men just unsatisfied what don't you get
Jim I think this is probably the last
one pray for the but they're doing a
Jeffersons and an all in the family
cat like a show in honor of that guy
that created it the producer guy
yo salir oh no I'm in there no one there
yeah nothin there so all look at this
cast here Woody Harrelson Merstham a
Jamie Foxx Wanda Sykes what's it called
all in the family all that was a huge
show back in 70s right I was right and
the Jeffersons if you want to watch
great acting and great writing God
please let me see this thing - what is
it this is just like that promo for it
Tomei it's a leak in first like
Barinholtz Stephen Tobolowsky it's Wanda
Sykes please and I'm playing Louise
Jefferson in the Jets dammit
let's do it again okay
it's Anthony Anderson and I'm playing
Henry Jefferson I'm playing Gloria
sniffing I'm playing Edith bunker you
know playing mr. Bentley I'm playing
Mike meathead stivic playing George
Jefferson in the Jeffersons and I'm
playing Archie Bunker and all in the
family I'll tell to those people today
this show is live another thing life
could be the end of everything I might
say that's the show
TuneIn it's gonna be a play it was gonna
be cool say it used to be filmed in
front of a live studio audience right it
was in so it was like it was melon like
a play and all these actors came from
the stage so they were all phenomenal
it's just like [ __ ] that's cool
and it was shot that way so they walk in
and people would start clapping yeah
it's a clap yeah and they'd have to wait
that's cool they were such great shows
man oh god Alan says Jamie Foxx man he
would I know
yeah [ __ ] both of them do you think they
can do the same stuff though nowadays
that they did on those shows back then
no like the way they talked then I don't
think a lot of us are being racist
racist a lot of were really mean to like
women Archie Bunker was a bigot yeah
they can't do it now he was give me like
your water but he was always kind of
thought it was such a great show because
he was always kind of like prove wrong
or a boys told me but then I cuvette a
dress he was what a lot of Americans
were I mean he was he was a yeah
working-class guy and and they were just
showing you what what you know it was a
really good way to change people's minds
actually The Jeffersons is a phenomenal
she I'll watch that for sure bring up
300 Jefferson to the Sun finally gone up
there we go yeah that's it cool man yeah
you know yeah are you on the road this
week do ya I gotta I just want to go
through the Jeffersons man it's a great
show dude no I bet I'm sure dude
Indianapolis June 6 7 8 yeah now you've
brought me down okay I don't want to go
through that history every comedy club
and then we had Las Vegas June 15th
that's almost sold out dude you and I in
Vegas how about moving on though moving
on up to the Mafia surely room yeah or
lands I got Tempe improv new date June
20 21 and 22 Tempe improv you've been
widowed Tempe than Phoenix
well no I'm not doing Phoenix anymore
they have to take you take that off the
website yeah done 10 B 20 June 20 21 22
oh yes yeah I'm in Cleveland next week
Thursday Friday Saturday
hilarities Cleveland Doc Brown can get
you some next thursday friday saturday
and then burbank one-night-only
burbank california flappers one night
Vegas with Kalin on the 15th of June and
then just added is Calgary and Brea that
is Brad the Basie Orange County get your
tickets now tea fat K Dom gives you some
if you miss my special you can still get
it on demand now on Showtime go to
Showtime compro moco job you get 30 days
of free Showtime you're welcome you're
welcome
get you some dude then we're at the
comic store tomorrow night dude
day night buddy I'm excited is that app
pal that it I think that's it buddy I
think that's it I think that's it I
think we had a good good party let's
continue the history lesson of
Jeffersons on Wednesday movin on up to
these songs
all right route this the funk kid route